I think the beautiful Mullen put it
perfectly every man deserves the
opportunity to grow a little bit of
luxury ladies and gentlemen more
importantly mo bros and mo sisters for
the next 17 minutes I'm going to share
with you my movember journey and how
through that journey we've redefined
charity we're redefining the way
prostate cancer researchers are working
together throughout the world and I hope
through that process that I inspire you
to create something significant in your
life something significant that will go
on and make this world a better place so
the most common question I get asked I'm
going to answer it now so I don't have
to do it over drinks tonight is how did
this come about how do you Movember
start well normally a charity starts
with the cause and someone that is
directly affected by a cause they then
go on to create an event and beyond that
a foundation to support that pretty much
in every case that's how a charity
starts not so with Movember Movember
started in a very traditional Australian
Way was on a Sunday afternoon it was my
brother and a mate having a few beers
and I watching the world go by had a few
more beers and I had the conversation
turned to 70s fashion
and how everything manages to come back
into style and few more beers so there
has to be some stuff that hasn't come
back then one more beer and was whatever
happened to the mustache why hasn't that
made a comeback so there's a lot more
beers and then the day ended with a
challenge to bring the mustache back so
in Australia mo is slang from the stache
so we renamed the month november
Movember and created some pretty basic
rules which still stand today and they
are start the month clean-shaven rock
and mustache not a beard not a go to
your moustache for the 30 days of
november and then we agreed that we
would come together at the end of the
month have a mustache themed party an
award a prize for the best and of course
the worst moustache now trust me when
you're growing a mustache back in 2003
and there were 30 of us back then and
this is before the ironic hipster
mustache movement
it created a lot of controversy so my
boss wouldn't let me go and see clients
my girlfriend at the time who's no
longer my girlfriend hated it parents
would shuffle kids away from us but we
came together at the end of the month
and we celebrated our journey it was a
real journey and we had a lot of fun and
in 2004 I said to the guys that was so
much fun we need to legitimize you so we
can get away with it year on year so we
started thinking about that we were
inspired by the women around us and all
they were doing for breast cancer we
thought you know what there's nothing
for men's health why is that why why
can't we combine growing in the stache
and do something for men's health and I
started to research that topic and
discovered prostate cancer is the male
equivalent of breast cancer in terms of
the number of men that died from it and
diagnosed with it but there was nothing
for this cause so we married growing a
mustache with prostate cancer and then
we created our tagline which is changing
the face of men's health and that
eloquently describes a challenge
changing your appearance for the 30 days
and also the outcome that we're trying
to achieve getting men engaged in the
health having them have a better
understanding about the health risks
that they face so with that model I then
cold called the CEO of the prostate
cancer foundation I said to him I've got
the most amazing idea that's going to
transform your organization and I didn't
want to share with him the idea over the
phone so I convinced him to meet with me
for coffee in Melbourne in 2004 we sat
down i shared with in my vision of
getting men growing mustaches across
australia raising awareness for this
cause and funds for his organization I
needed a partnership to legitimately do
that and I said we're going to come
together at the end we're gonna have a
mustache themed party we can have djs
we're going to celebrate life and we're
going to change the face of men's health
and you just looked at me in laughed and
said said Adam that's a really novel
idea but we're an ultra conservative
organization
we can't have anything to do with you so
I paid for coffee that day and he's
parting comment as we shook hands was
listen if you happen to raise any money
out of this will gladly take it so my
lesson that year was persistence and we
persisted and we got 450 guys growing
mustaches and together we raise fifty
four thousand dollars we donated every
cent to that to the prostate cancer
foundation of australia and that
represented at the time the single
biggest donation that ever received so
from that day forward my life has become
about a moustache every day this morning
I wake up and go my life isn't about a
moustache essentially i'm a moustache
farmer and my season is november
so in 2005 the campaign got more
momentum was more successful in
Australia and then New Zealand and then
in 2006 we came to a pivotal point we
was consuming so much of our time after
hours on weekends that we thought we
either need to close this down or figure
a way to fund Movember so that I could
quit my job and go and spend more time
in the organization and take it to the
next level it's really interesting when
you try and figure a way to fund the
fundraising organization built off
growing mustaches let me tell you
there's not too many people interested
in investing in that not even the
prostate cancer foundation who had
raised about 1.2 million dollars for
that stage so again we persisted and
fosters brewing came to the party and
gave us our first ever sponsorship and
that was enough for me to quit my job at
he consulting on the side and leading
into Movember 2006 we'd run through all
the money from fosters would run through
all the money I had and essentially we
had no money left and we convinced all
our suppliers creative agencies web
development agencies hosting companies
what not to delay their billing until
December so we'd racked up at this stage
about six hundred thousand dollars worth
of debt so if Movember 2006 didn't
happen the four founders well we would
have been broke we would have been
homeless sitting on the street with
moustaches
so we thought you know what if that's
the worst thing that happens so what
we're going to have a lot of fun doing
it and taught us the importance of
taking risks and really smart risks then
in early 2007 a really interesting thing
happened we had mo bros from from canada
from the US and from the UK emailing us
and calling us and saying hey there's
nothing for prostate cancer bring this
campaign to these countries so we
thought why not let's do it so i
cold-called the CEO of prostate cancer
canada and i said to him i have this
most amazing concept it's going to
transform your organization I don't want
to tell you about it now but will you
meet with me if I fly all the way to
Toronto so I flew here met down on front
street east and we sat in the boardroom
I said right he's my vision up of
getting men grow mustaches all across
Canada raising awareness and funds for
your organization and he looked at me
and laughed and said Adam sounds like a
really novel idea but we're all true
conservative organization I've heard
this before I know I know how it goes
but he said we will partner with you but
we're not going to invest in it you need
to figure a way to bring this campaign
across here and make it work so what we
did was we took some of the money that
we raised in Australia to bring the
campaign across to this country of the
US and UK and we did that because we
knew if this was successful we could
raise infinitely more money globally
than we could just in Australia and that
money fuels research and that research
will get us to a cure we're not about
finding an Australian cure or a Canadian
cure we're about finding the cure so in
2007 we bought the campaign across here
and it was it set the stage for the
campaign it wasn't as successful as we
thought it would be we'll sort of very
gung-ho with that success in Australia
and New Zealand that stage so that you
really taught us the importance of being
patient and really understanding the
local market before you become so bold
as to set lofty targets but what I'm
really pleased to say is in 2010
Movember became a truly global movement
was just pipped at the post in terms of
the number one fundraising campaign in
the world last year we had four hundred
and fifty thousand mowbray spread across
the world and together we raise 77
million dollars
and that makes Movember now the biggest
funder of prostate cancer research and
support programs in the world and that
is an amazing achievement when you think
about asked growing mustaches and for us
we have redefined charity our ribbon is
a hairy ribbon our ambassadors are the
mo bros and the most sisters and I think
that's been fundamental to our success
we hand across our brand now campaign to
those people we let them embrace it and
interpret it in their own way so now I
live in Los Angeles because the prostate
cancer foundation of the u.s. is based
there and I always get asked by the
media down there because it's so
celebrity-driven who are your celebrity
ambassadors and I say to them last year
we'll fortunate enough to have 450,000
celebrity ambassadors what what do you
mean it's like every single person every
single mobro and most sister but
participates in Movember is our
celebrity ambassador and that was so so
important and fundamental to our success
now what I want to share with you is one
of my most touching Movember moments and
it happened here in Toronto last year at
the end of the campaign I was out with
the team was the end of Movember we'd
had a great campaign and minus would had
a fair share a beer that night but I
said you know what I think we've got one
more bar left in us so we piled into a
taxi and this was our taxi driver and I
was sitting in the back seat and he
turned around and said where you going I
said how that is an amazing mustache
and he said I'm doing it for Movember
and I said so am I and I said tell me
you Movember story and he goes listen I
know it's about men's health I know it's
about prostate cancer but this is for
breast cancer I said okay that's
interesting he goes last year my mum
passed away from breast cancer in Sri
Lanka because we couldn't afford proper
treatment for her and he said this
mustache is my tribute to my mum we sort
of all choked up in the back of the taxi
and I didn't tell him who I was because
I didn't he was appropriate and I just
shook his hand I said thank you so much
your mom would be so proud and from that
moment I realized that Movember is so
much more than a mustache having a joke
it's about each person coming to this
platform embracing it in their own way
and being significant in their own life
for us now at Movember we really focus
on three program areas and having a true
impact awareness and education survivor
support programs and research now we
always focus naturally on how much we
raise this is a very tangible outcome
but for me awareness and education is
more important the funds of raids
because I know that is changing and
saving lives today it's probably best
example by a young guy that I met at
south by southwest in austin texas at
the start of the year he came up to me
and said thank you for starting Movember
i said thank you for doing movember I
looked at him I was like I'm pretty sure
you can't grow a mustache
and I said watch movember story and he
said I grew the worst and stash ever but
I went home for Thanksgiving dinner and
pretty quickly the conversation around
the table turned to what the hell was
going on and we took a talk to them
about movember and then after that my
dad came up to me and at the age of 20
sits for the first time ever I had a
conversation with my dad one-on-one
about men's health I had a conversation
with my dad about prostate cancer and I
learned that my grandfather had prostate
cancer and I was able to share with my
dad that he was twice as likely to get
that disease and he didn't know that and
he hadn't been getting screened for it
so now that guy is getting screened for
prostate cancer so those conversations
getting men engaged in this at whatever
age is so critically important and in my
view so much more important than the
funds we raise now to the funds we raise
and research and how we're redefining
research we fund prostate cancer
foundation's now in 13 countries we
literally fund hundreds if not thousands
of institutions and researchers around
the world when we looked at this more
recently we realize there's a real lack
of collaboration going on even with
institutions that alone nationally
little own globally and this is not
unique to prostate cancer this is this
is a cancer research the world over and
so we said right we redefine charity we
need to redefine the way these guys
operate how do we do that so what we did
was we created our global action plan
we're taking ten percent of what's
raised in each country now and putting
it into a global fund we've got the best
prostate cancer scientific minds in the
world that look after that fund and they
come together each year and identified
the number one priority and that last
year was getting a better screening test
so they identified that as a priority
and then they've gone and recruited now
300 researchers from around the world
that are studying that topic essentially
the same topic so now we're funding them
to the tune of about five or six million
dollars to collaborate and bringing them
together
and that's a unique thing in the cancer
world and we know through that
collaboration it will accelerate
outcomes and that's how we're redefining
the research world so what I know about
my movember journey is that with a
really creative idea with passion with
persistence and a lot of patience for
mates for mustaches can inspire a room
full of people and that room full of
people can go on and inspire a city and
that city is Melbourne my home and that
city can go on and inspire a state and
that state can go on and inspire a
nation and beyond that you can create a
global movement that is changing the
face of men's health my name is Adam
groaning and that's my story thank
you